what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves an
official trailer for Five Nights at
Freddy's we're running late to this one
uh it's not John's fault but I gotta
blame him for some reason John why'd you
make us late because I'm too scared and
I don't want to have nightmares G
I wish I didn't say yeah for this I
don't really have a good back and forth
here guys leave a like on this video if
you're excited for Five Nights at
Freddy's also if you didn't catch the
memo John Coy and myself we are going to
be having a panel at Comic-Con where we
won't be talking about Five Nights at
Freddy's but it'll be the Saturday July
22nd either way if you're going to be
attending Comic-Con would love to have
you in attendance in our whole audience
section that would be lovely anywho guys
let's get to it
thank you
hi this is Mike I was just calling to
see if that job that you offered was
still available yeah
yeah the security guard I will take
anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the
kids they shut it down years ago the
owners just not ready to let it go yet
I will work and you will sleep I
understand
oh no
gonna put their child in danger
just keep your eyes on the monitor
nice welcome to Freddy Fazbear's we're
fantasy and fun come to life
oh no
we must be new security guards can I uh
help you officer have you met them yet
I don't know who
them
they're here
wow
[Music]
awesome oh damn they really brought them
to life yeah
[Music]
in the 80s kids went missing
Freddy's top to bottom hello
and find nothing they never found them
that's why the play shut down
children possessing dying robots
ghost children thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make her
like them Bobby
oh I love that they've really brought
them their life so accurately oh it's
too late
Bobby go
this looks intense
[Music]
I wanna play a game where two
no no where are those no
damn he's getting out he's getting out
yeah outbreak into the real world all
right well I enjoy that trailer quite a
bit I must say that was real enjoyable
cheesy camp but it also looks really
great I mean the animatronics look
awesome here they they feel like
genuinely practical like do we know what
who made them do you know I don't know
what what effects house or you know but
uh you guys know who made them but it
seems like they're perfectly arranged
for this because you know in the games
obviously it's it's the look and they're
rendered in 3D so yeah it's like the
perfect way to bring them to life
because they look exactly like the game
but they also look real yeah I love I
love the SX and that's probably the most
important thing you got to capture at
first you know because obviously this
franchise has a massive fan base to it
and it's gonna have like the story and
the horror and a lot of the fun capitals
the characters there's so many things
that you've got to get right but the
first thing that anyone's going to truly
judge this movie on as we know when it
comes to adapting IP is what do the
animatronics look like and they they
captured the animatronics perfectly here
in my personal opinion as someone who's
only dabbled with Five Nights at
Freddy's and doesn't really know the
lore all that well but speaking of
Lauren all that I'm on the freeze frame
here of Matthew Lillard from the scream
franchise where it says his his name is
Steve Ragland uh but I heard he was
playing William Afton who is the
co-owner and the uh like I think the one
responsible for murdering the ghost
children didn't murder you know merge
the children right so I don't know if
this is just a cover-up right yeah yeah
if this is just a cover-up or not
um says that I'd like to see the
trailers is totally had me questioning
the information that was communicated my
way uh regardless though I am very
excited as screaming being one of my
all-time favorite franchises and
screaming my all-time favorite horror
movies to see Matthew Lillard step back
in to this genre because I don't really
know from anything else without a paddle
was I hear that uh maybe then Scooby-Doo
never seen it nope so so yeah but
overall I mean I think this trailer has
a really cool hook to it and especially
with finding a way to keep it of real a
personal tale with trying to make sure
your sister who you didn't bring to work
doesn't turn into one of them and having
to protect her but this is Five Nights
at Freddy's and I am hoping that it does
end ultimately it seems like with the
way the trailer is progressing that it
does end with her ultimately becoming
one of the animatronics I hope it goes
down that path I want to see that little
girl die that is my personal wish I
always root for that that's right little
kid murdered do it you cowards yeah yeah
what thoughts do you have I agree
children dying more child murder in my
movies I mean I would be surprised but I
mean it would certainly be a sign that
they're willing to go hard if they take
it in that direction and that kind of
reminded me of something that's like a
little bit hearkening to an older kind
of Cinema too you know like the 80s or
90s kind of thing where it's like yeah
this young guy down on his luck needs a
job and he's got to take his kid sister
with him because he's essentially now
the man of the house Etc
um and so that's also a neat way I think
to differentiate this from something
like Willie's Wonderland which obviously
you know a certain amount of people even
though Five Nights at Freddy's is like
way bigger of a global phenomenon you
know there's still that like who beat
who to the movie punch and I think
that's also where the design uh of the
animatronics being so faithful is
another really just lovely thing to see
because yeah like not even being the
biggest expert on the lore in the game
or whatever myself just like seeing
those designs and and the fact that yeah
they lend themselves so well to live
action even though part of the whole
alloris Scott coffin's games was the
fact that they were made to look cute
and they came out looking creepy just
because that's how his animation is but
even the animatronic layers and then uh
and all that underneath like the way the
gears are certainly like proprietary of
the game and uh yeah it looks
appropriately creepy like I like that
this trailer gave us a lot more uh just
you know imagery intensity but it's not
really like shining major light past
what the teaser trailer gave us so
there's still a good amount of just like
I don't know like mystery as to like
what elements of the game are going to
be really explored through the plot but
you know you've got all the nuts and
bolts right here you know it's clear
that we've got everything that we need
for like a chilling good time and yeah
something that looks like it could play
a little bit broadly in terms of like
what ages could get into it without
being like for kids well I'm what I'm
really hoping for too is that they
managed to really hone in on the more
simplistic horror elements that the game
provided yeah because this trailer gave
us a surprising amount of exposition and
a surprising amount of explanation as to
what's going on like in fact I was
that's the part that surprised me a
little bit is because
this story has such a a simple hook of a
person who works a night shift at this
kids this abandoned kids place and then
you know like animatronics come to life
it's a haunting it's like a simple
premise of a hook and then they kind of
gave away a lot of the lore already yes
which is something you normally get in a
movie way later like closer towards the
finale or something like that as you're
unpacking the mystery yeah and I think
it's something that built over multiple
games too yeah so I really want to
experience the the tension and the
horror the actual natural Hook and the
the beginning stages of Five Nights at
Freddy's is the part of it that I feel
like is the thing that you know like you
could obviously take the lore and then
you know put it into a screenplay but
the experience the emotional terror is
the thing that I you really gotta
experience
yeah that's the part where you know I
was like of course we want to get the
lower ride and we want to get the look
right but it's the horror that you guys
want the most attention of looking at
the screens and not running out of
flashlights
yeah yeah exactly and where is it going
to come from and yeah like who's
sneaking past what camera is about to
jump into this door and you know devour
my soul but either way I'm excited for
Josh Hutcherson to die in this movie
he'll die he won't come back for the
sequel but they don't come back for part
three and it'll be awesome with a big
beard if you know it goes and I hope
they do that alrighty guys so what'd you
think about the Five Nights at Freddy's
trailer leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe leave a like also
uh let's send this with a
Kevin smart my dude what's really smart
is to spend your night in a janky
children's play place you know break
into your local Chuck E cheese and just
you know squat there man
you could probably liven up the you know
just experience of all the people
working there take the animatronics that
are there and move them around you know
inhabit their uh visitors yourself crawl
into the gears and walk around and
terrorize the community and that's the
way you'll leave your mark on this
that's your child and then we'll be
doing five nights at Kevin's soon enough
you and your kid praise be uh lift up
your hearts we lift them up to the Lord
stay holy and uh we'll we'll catch you
soon stay fresh as well and uh and we
won't haunt you so much love be well
[Music]